hello everybody
and welcome to this webinar on statues
and statutes around table on the french
caribbean
in the age of hashtag must fall and
hashtag
black lives matter let me begin
by acknowledging that indigenous peoples
and nations
including mohegan machine to get pequot
eastern piquot shatikot golden hill
pegasus
niantic and the quinnipiac and other
algonquian-speaking peoples have sworded
through generations
the lands and waterways of what is now
the state
of connecticut we honor and respect the
enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples and nations
and this land i also acknowledge that we
meet today within an institution
that has benefited from the enslaved
labor of african
men and women
my name is cecil from and i am on the
faculty of the history of art department
at yale where i teach african and latin
american art history
i am here today in this capacity but
also as a member of the french caribbean
diaspora
as many of my compatriots i was born and
raised in martinique
but left the island to pursue higher
education
in europe and really never returned
first let me say a word about the
organization about time together this
afternoon or morning
i will begin by introducing our
panelists and the session
and they will then share some remarks
for about 10 minutes
each uh will be followed by a roundtable
discussion
the three of us for 30 minutes we will
then open the floor
to q a for the reminder of our time
together
we invite you to ask questions using the
queen
q a function uh in zoom at
any time i will read the questions to
the panelists
and the audience uh once we get to uh
the
q a part of our time together if you
include your name
uh and any relevant background i will
share
that too
before going any further let me thank
professor steven peady
and the rhythm pro for offering a forum
to this conversation
um and thanks in particular to its
associate director
matthew taniko for making the event uh
technically and intellectually possible
i thank also every one of you for
joining us today
for what we hope will be a constructive
conversation i'm most grateful
of course to dr audrey celestin and
zacatotto
for responding positively to my call to
participate
in this forum
so many of you gathered here today
much more than i do about the topic but
for those
among us uh who are maybe not familiar
with martinique and its history
um i uh have uh prepared the shortest of
introductions
about the island focusing on the
protagonist
that um you will
hear about in the rest of the discussion
so martinique is a small island uh in uh
the caribbean
uh it's about in the middle of the of
the art uh that has been
french um uh so to speak since 1635
with the establishment on the island of
a settlement
by pierre billam de numbuk this pirate
looking guy here in 1636
uh as part of his plan the first
enslaved people
um joined the island were brought to the
island
and uh tensions soon rose with the
indigenous populations uh leading to the
massacre of kurds and arawak amerindians
in 1658.
the island would remain a sugarcane
plantation colony
for the following centuries
relying heavily on enslaved labor
the first abolition of slavery in the
french empire in 1794
did not reach the island whose plantar
class
had sided with the british at the time
in part to avoid that
abolition in 1804
josephine de boerne the wife of napoleon
becomes empress of france and a powerful
spokesperson
on behalf of the planters cos
she is associated in martinique and
elsewhere in the caribbean
with their institution of slavery in the
french empire
abolition will be seized not bestowed
on may 22nd 1848 in martinique
by the enslaved themself who was up
against slavery
in anticipation of the long awaited
decree
from the french assembly that had
declared emancipation
weeks before a decree closely associated
with french politician and abolitionist
victoria
in 1946 in the aftermath of world war
ii and under the leadership of emmy
cezaire deputy and mayor of fort de
france
the capital of martinique from 1945 to
2001
martinique became alongside a small
number of french so-called old colonies
a department of french it joined
the sovereignty of the french
state in full form that meant that it
was no longer
a colony and thus it gains
its current statutes as a teenager
i remember asking caesar why
departmentalization
and not independence with a look that i
now with the benefit of age recognized
as
annoyed benefits um his side stared at
me and answered
ask your grandparents that's what they
wanted
notably as part of a large project of
urban renewal
for for de france caesarea chose not to
remove the statues of josephine
chelsea or dynamic but to move them to
less prominent locations
where they received rounds after rounds
of
vernacular interventions defacing
spray painting etc
josephine famously lost her head in 1991
and has since been the site of street
art and militant
intervention she's often seen or she was
often seen doused in red blood
um on the right with a gilles legend etc
in recent decades the political
has been marked by increased
technicization of political debates
and a relative inability of local
political forces
to propose a political project in a
context of demographic decline
high unemployment increasing
inequalities
and the health scandal surrounding the
poisoning of the island
with claudicon an insecticide used in
banana agriculture
which was forbidden because of its
toxicity
in all of france and the european union
except in the french caribbean by
special derogation
granted to the planter's lobby
in the summer of 2020 as the city of for
the france had
already decided to remove increasingly
contested monuments
militants associated by all accounts
with the rouge vernon movement
named after the independence movement
flag
chelsea
the dramatic gesture spurred an
impassioned debate
in martinique and today it is the stakes
and significance of these gestures and
of their interpretation
that will be the topic of our roundtable
without further ado let me introduce to
you the two panelists
before we hear from them
first i'm delighted to introduce to you
audrey celestin
who is a social scientist and an
associate
in studies at the university of lille in
the north of france
her work focuses on migration memory
race and identity in france
in the french caribbean and the united
states
her first book la fabrique des
identities deals with the collective
tragedy of puerto ricans in new york
and french caribbeans in paris since the
mid 20th century
it was published in 2018 by cartela
she also published in family frances
in 2018 on the impact of migration
exile colonization race and identity
in the individual trajectories of four
generations of an ordinary french family
she also recently published davido comba
femme noir elive in 2020.
our second panelist is zakatoto
who is in his own words a writer and
entrepreneur
alternatively or at the same time
depends he says based in martinique he
created the online
review list in 2018 with writers
scholars photographers creators from
across the black diaspora
with most of the funding coming from his
dad's garden
he writes about martinique and the
caribbean mostly
and the current global zeitgeist he is
obsessed with cities
how you walk and live in them how the
experience of a specific place relates
to culture
policy and social economics
this obsession came to form in 2017 when
he started a comparative writing project
around colonial ideologies and legacies
how they translate into urban spaces and
the cultural dynamics
involved in different cases linking the
protest in charlottesville to what
happened in martinique in an earlier era
but also algeria paraguay china and
taiwan
finally this year he concluded the
series
he concluded in the series that the most
colonial place of all
is paris he also made the mistake
he says of starting a phd in history at
the university desenti
on political cultures and identity in
martinique
he is also foolish enough he says to
think
that he can start urban renovation
programs in for defense
and build one of eduard gleeson's old
dream
so let's uh now hear from
our two panelists well thank you very
much cecile for
the invitation and the opportunity to
have a discussion with
wii u and with zaka we've been talking a
lot about these topics in the
last year and even more so during the
last
six months but i'm happy to have this
new arena to
to to talk about all of these issues and
i think you were i mean
the summary synthesis that you provided
at the beginning of your
of your talk as an introduction was um
uh
that is actually very important because
we can
definitely see the events of this
summer down the summer and marching into
the summer 2020
as a sort of martinique conversion
of a more global phenomenon
but i actually think it's really
important to place it into the very
local
localized perspective and to put it uh
within
the framework of politics and society
in martinique since the
departmentalization of 1946
um as you said in 1946 representatives
from martinique whether
but also french guiana and iranian
island
opted for um and and
asked for um um departmentalization
and as a full incorporation into the
french
republic and even if the choice can be
and the fact that they love it for that
that they did a proposition lua
going to that in that direction was
then considered to be sort of a
misguided
and a wrong uh decision uh
when contextualized uh it was actually a
pretty pragmatic choice and that's how
they've been defending it and above all
it's important to consider it and it's
something that local historians have
been
showing as the result
of a long struggle for equality
driven by a number of calculations and
a strong sense of history since the
abolition of
um of slavery in 1848
and um basically this moment of
departmentalization
was considered to be a sort of promise
of overturning
the colonial relationship between uh
metropolitan france
and its old colonies and via colony and
it was
seen as an important moment in that
as an important moment for completing
equality
for uh repairing emancipation's failures
and if there was a true belief at the
time that departmentalization would
be so would be this sort of would allow
for true equality
with all french citizens uh within the
framework
of the french republic political
practices at the time
the forms of exercising power on parts
of
uh high civil servants the prefe locally
um the very partial extension of social
and economic rights
um the strong repression of
political movements all of this fed
the very strong criticism of the
departmentalization process just a few
years after it was voted
it was actually actually considered by
many
as a failure and um
a set of lies on part of the french
republic
to actually rent a real um
equality and emancipation and this
criticism
the wide array of criticisms against
departmentalization process
became a very important fault line in
local politics
it fed nationalism it fed the desire for
independence
or political autonomy or a wide array of
political imagination regarding what to
make
of these uh territories it guided many
people in their militants
in the militant and political sphere in
the way they would think
about uh a true political
social and cultural emancipation and
actually zac i could talk about it about
true
economic emancipation as well people
just because of the
um false promises of departmentalization
tried started to think about all of that
creative stuff
failed succeeded in some extent and um
all of that history and really there's a
lot of work that remains to
to be done on all of these political
social cultural experiences
that has work uh um is probably
i mean it's clearly part of this effort
that we can see
nowadays in scholarship to fill the gaps
of the contemporary history of
of of martinique i'm thinking about the
work of uh
um valerian as well who's a
young phd candidate in history in
martinique as well
but all of these moments that still need
to be
uh scholarly documented uh
are key to understand the way
uh a number of people viewed the events
of 2020 around commemoration around the
status
etc etc and i think it was very
important so what happened exactly you
mentioned
it on may 22nd 2020 it was a day of
commemoration of the insurrection of the
slaves
in 1848 uh and the year of the abolition
of slavery
uh in the french colonies and we learned
i was in paris where i've been living
for 22 years just
like you i had to i left after the
baccalaureate
even if i i tried to go back often and i
work on
the uh martinique and polity and society
but we learned the destruction of our
two studies of victoria in martinique
most people didn't cry over these two
statues and a lot of people didn't
totally care but a lot of them didn't
quite understand what was going on
and that's that moment i wondered i was
like
it's may 22nd i'm not supposed to have
like construction work on her
that day it's our you know bang day and
um
and i did not totally understand what
was going on at first uh
the day had been marked by lots of
commemorations in several places that
had been
uh transformed into places of memory uh
such as the climate dwelling
lots of strong events actually happened
that day and then there was that
um a few days uh after actually
more than a month after that the statue
of ernest de bruyne was also aborted
uh he was a politician at the end of the
19th century he belonged to the social
group of
the roulette uh became a representative
he was the president of the general
council of martinique
most people in martinique have no idea
who is exactly unless they approach
martinique and people don't know really
don't really know much about
about him there was no direct claim or
real debate on the figure of
the man who was not totally uh well
known
in and people didn't really know what to
make of
of of that event and then at the end of
july
the status of de nombre and josephine de
bruyne were also destroyed by the same
group apparently uh and um
in in that case as you said in the case
of
of josephine um
her status had already been the site of
various degradations of her history
uh and the most important one being that
she had been beheaded at the beginning
of the 90s
which was a very impressive mark i
remember
it when i was little probably at the
time when we
met at the beginning of the 90s and it
was actually a very
powerful thing to to see to walk by this
status without a head and with all kinds
of degradations and transformations over
time
and so even though people would not cry
over this colonial there was no colonial
nostalgia on the part of
any martinique regarding all of these
symbols there was
some level of misunderstanding but also
of understanding that the situation of
martin martinique is
generally pretty bad in terms of
unemployment in terms of the sanitary
crisis and the health crisis and the
scandal
over claudicon and so people have lots
of reason it's something that we were
discussing when preparing this session
there are like 1000 reasons to burn down
a lot in martinique
today at the contemporary era these
specific
actions were not totally understood
because
precisely of this history of
interventions of people from
martinique on their own urban setting i
think that that
is going to talk about about that and in
the media comments regarding these
events
uh you had i mean the the distractions
were attributed to several
generic actors the revolted youths
the activists of the vernor movement
the people of martinique the people is
also a category that's
been often um often mobilized
and um it was interesting to kind of try
and understand
who was behind these events but to
understand that
behind this event you had those some
militants that
were known in martinique as because
they're innovating they're really young
in having a lot on social media
and are presenting themselves as
anti-clothing
activists um so there was this
connection that was established between
them and the anti-claudica movement
there was some connections as well uh
with the notion of
reparation in the uh um in the um
public uh sphere but there was clearly
an
indication of a general problem
regarding the issue of reparation the
issue of the health scandal of
claudicon without really understanding
whether the repertoire of action
was totally accurate or whether
this was um i mean there was
a difficulty to understand the whole the
whole thing
um what was interesting was the
reactions
uh to uh the uh to the um to the event
um from the outset a number of
politicians condemned the destruction of
the status of victor schelcher
um and the mayor's reaction was of
the mayor for the france reaction was
basically to speed up the setting up of
the commission that he had already
planned on
having on memory and transmission and in
which for full disclosure i was asked to
sit in dhaka is also part of the of the
commission
the commission brings together academics
professors associative activists
um and a wide array of persons of
several generations to offer space for
discussion on on these issues with the
idea
of setting up short medium and long-term
actions regarding
these questions one of the very
immediate action that was
organized was the setting up of a
senator
which was a sort of public arena in
which the public and people
and including the some of the people
within the movement that was claiming
uh the um the the unborn of the status
to this scanning the open air in july uh
in fort de france to debate on the
issues of status in the public space
and um as i was um telling you guys um
yesterday it was
very interesting and impressive to see
how
almost immediately while the events were
unfolding like this capacity to actually
discuss about them to talk about all of
the
problems issues contradictions uh having
old politicians younger activists
actually exchanging on
um the issue and being able to have like
a sort of reflexive
notion on this each defending his way to
do politics and each defending
his way to look at the at the event uh
and um reflecting on uh
on recent history and longer history it
was a very
interesting and important moment that to
me has to be placed
within the long series of experiences
um formulated by people in martinique
since the departmentalization to try and
think
about ways to emancipate uh
themselves what's interesting is
as you said in your introduction one of
the issues and i think that i can
almost reached my 10 minutes um one i
think that one of the um
interesting issues that that we have all
of that in martinique people able to
think about
things people who have been imagining
futures and emancipate
futures for martinique and at the same
time this sort of high
technicization of political issues that
to me cons
constitute part of the problems in
marketing that we are discussing whether
this article of the constitution is
better than this other one article of
the constitution
without having political actors able to
formulate at a broader level a sort of
political project
that people can all embrace and i'm
sorry i concluded like pretty rapidly
but i'll let dhaka continue thank you
thank you very much uh zaka let's hear
from you
um hello everyone how do i share my
screen
uh i i did a small presentation
basically just pictures
um how do i activate the
oh yeah share screen here you go i'll
pop up this one
sure can you see the picture it's fine
okay um
so i um i prepared something so hi my
name is zekka
thank you for the introduction sorry
um uh first of all i i would like to be
clear about homestalking
um uh because often in in these
uh in this kind of of talks about
um when we have experts and historians
and people to write whatever subjects
we tend to put in one category people
will act and people will think
um and i think it's very troubling it's
very troubling in a black perspective
because i don't think at some point in
history there was a difference between
a black activist and black intellectuals
uh this is
in pretty much all parts of the diaspora
something that is very linked
um and i believe that in my case it's
also kind of
a dichotomy or alliance or um
i don't know a problem um
i would also to add that i i
really don't care about the the violent
fate of the statue in
i mean the worker relics um
and and they did not fit with my
ideology i identify myself
as an independentist basically since i
was born i was born
in this fight i for me
or whatever are historical figures
they can be important in some or related
to my history but
i don't feel like they belong more
than people coming from actually like
the the enslaved fights
violence can be legitimate um but i
would rather say
violence can be pertinent um
and to further the fight um i'm 36 i i
feel like i'm
still a bit young and and i don't want
to do what was done before me
and so for that if i some point i say
hey i want to
how do i how do i further the fight then
i i
for me what i study is is kind of a
benchmark
what was done before me and what i can
do after that
um and and we have the resources
uh to actually think about that
so that's why i wrote a little
presentation called muscle
already happened never truly ends and
then what
uh i'm gonna be provocative um
but it's interesting to go across the
diaspora it's interesting to
to go deep into our history and see what
was done
uh how it goes across communities in the
diaspora
and some of the lessons also that can be
learned from some of those experiences
um so of course uh i believe most of the
american autism
and pretty much all of the audience i've
heard about the challenge process in
2017
august uh where basically there was a
right wing
uh a protest to protect a statue of
general lee i think that's the statue of
general lee
who was basically the the general
leading the army uh
um to maintain the institution of
slavery if i use
their language uh the language of the
confederacy
um and there was a counter protest and
uh
a young woman died uh i forgot her name
i'm sorry
um and and this part uh global
conversation
about the issue of colonial legacy is
very very pregnant in the u.s but it's
printed pretty much anywhere where there
was an empire
and there were colonies i think it's
it's it's everywhere asia
africa and europe itself because europe
celebrates its own
you know conquerors admirals
merchants heroes pirates
um and at that time
uh in august um that sparked something
in me because when i was a kid
so 1991 i was seven years old and
and i knew some of the people
uh this is another i think this is the
arlington memorial
in uh in virginia as well
with the mummy crying for the
confederacy soldier and
this happened so 1991 the the statue of
jesus was beheaded
uh and blood was poured on it and um
and those guys were my heroes because
basically in the 80s
where it was the height and the peak of
the last really violent fights
in the caribbean in french in guadalupe
in in martinique and in french guarana
it was basically almost the last wave of
caribbean independence
which you know was not fruitful um
and there were you know there was
bombings and
and fights and and and militancy and
people were
hiding weapons and and it was happening
everywhere there was bombing in paris
there was bombing in
in martinique in guadalupe like almost
like 10 20 times a year
um and that was very serious um
of course it didn't pan out it was not
successful
and and what happened was um
some of the militants at least some of
the you know
cells that were in martinique uh decided
to go
uh and and see the statue of josephine
so the impress
josephine of france was married to
napoleon
and beheaded and pour blood on it and
that was
this statue is a paradox because at the
same time
you're saying that you know it's over
this kind of heritage this call your
heritage
uh because this statue was was basically
erected in the in
i think mid mid 19th century to
celebrate
the union between the french empire i
think it was the second empire at the
time
and and between france and maritime
and how this bond was materialized by
josephine
who was born a white planter in
martinique
but married to a french emperor so how
that ball was there forever
this statue was located in the center of
orofrost so the main city
and at the center of the savannah which
is you know the
uh basically central park uh it's
actually those two places have the same
function and history
in in the new cities of the new world um
and to be headed um it was a way to say
you know
this thing and the way it was
established and the way it was
symbolized is over
but at the same time it was also
a symbolic act because the military
action and the violent action
and the political action was not
successful
so it's a simple liquid
but in concrete maybe it is not
you know a win um
and it kind of reflects very well what
happened in martinique
so i will go back a little bit and we
will talk about the history of all of us
uh which was basically a colonial city
and and the seat of power
of all the colonial powers of all the
elements of colonial power
in martinique as in the french
government
uh when it was a colony and still a
little bit
uh of the white planters called the biki
of
um you know the the the former free
slave or free of colors
uh or people who became wealthy after
the abolition
and basically where kind of pro friends
and pro
assimilation um and how this
got twisted uh basically
um after world war ii uh thanks to two
things
um first there was uh
people coming from the countryside uh
who moved massively to the city so that
changed the demographics of the city
people were voting were not you know
assimilating themselves
as as the winners of of colonization
they were
the former uh forced laborers you know
exploited labor and basically they could
finally express some political power
and you know meeting with uh
multiple generations of intellectuals
and
and writers so he misses her susan josie
ronnie menil
were ferociously anticlinalist and
uh um
made a political offer to take the reins
of the capital
and transform it and this is what
happened because um
so the movement was called negritude um
they were claiming themselves to be
cannibals
and they actually eat all a lot of the
political power a lot of those chronic
legacy from the inside
and from the outside they change the
function of some places
um so here for example on this picture
you have these gates
uh i think in english it's called porto
de trisotener in french and
uh trin centenarium gates i i think
transition
okay good translation um uh
which was erected in 1935 um
because as cece mentioned earlier uh
the colony of martin was established in
1635 so he was to celebrate
300 years of the empire and 300 days of
where
the empire started one minute okay
and and and basically what happened is
that
caesar was mayor for 50 years
transformed his gate
not by toppling it not
by destroying it but by changing what
was inside
what was inside was basically a center
for
um cultural actions that was to
uh celebrate black arts bring in the
diasporas
teach people culture uh art and
all kinds of things and actually a lot
of very prestigious things were
done there i cannot go into detail sadly
i only have one minute
and and there was just you can see at
the basement one modification that was
made
there was a fresco that was done in the
80s early 80s by an artist called coco
and and basically that celebrates the
insurrection of the caribbeans
um so there was this also symbolic
reversal
of of what this gate meant um
so change of function so that's a
political action a real concrete action
and then uh like a symbolic
transformation of the place
um just one conclusion i would not have
the time to go through algeria and what
happened to the structure statue in
paraguay
basically you keep some of those symbols
as reminders
of what happened before rather than
erase them as if they will never come
back again
because you know democracy or in culture
or
or in human societies things you know
tend to come back
and i choose this last symbol uh which
is you know
a boulevard in the u.s called martin
luther king boulevard
and i remember when i was uh when i was
20 years old i was reading this comic
called the boondocks
and one of the characters of these
comics was pointing out that
the most some of the most dangerous
places and avenues in the united states
are places called martin luther king
boulevard
and when i was a teenager um in in the
small city
i'm from the countryside of martinique
there was this place named after a very
famous
journalist in san diego martini called
reality care
and this place turned out with the
people from my age before i went to
school with and then the younger people
after me was basically
a dope selling area
and i remember there was there was i
suppose military was sent
to clean that street
but the name was there the change of
names were there the symbols were
changed
but the concrete what was happening at
that time in that city despite you know
the nice name of the street
and the fact that we reminisce of our
own black history and of our fights and
of everything
it was it was not good it was not good
and
i think that it's very interesting to
understand that um
and that must fall is not the end
thank you very much becca um
so uh i think we can uh come together
now
for uh a little bit of a panel uh
discussion
um but before we start i would like to
invite
um members of the audience to feel free
to send their questions
uh starting now in the q
a function as we continue to discuss and
we will get to them uh
uh very soon um so thank you for doing
that
and we are definitely recording them for
um
to get to them um
later um
i i was really struck by
the ways in which uh we are dealing
with a very dense terrain uh in terms of
uh
uh contemporary history uh in martinique
that's something that
um audrey you you mentioned um
in uh the sphere of political
um action and zakah also
uh relating it with the urban space um
and um the urban space and
uh and the ways in which it's been
re-signified
over time um and so my a question i had
for you something i would like us to
discuss is the ways in which
um the many layers of
um political actions and um
uh uh monumental
um uh marking of space
have been not uh always
meeting with each other in say
um you know uh decades since the
departmentalization
um and so what do you think uh has been
um the challenges uh uh in this regards
that have been met
and the challenges that have not been
met in in a way that
led to um uh the summer of 2020
well maybe i can i can start i really
think that
what you're referring to is basically
one of the very
important issues for people who work on
public policies of memory
on memory from a very i'm a political
scientist so i'm going to talk about my
field
but really this notion that um
you cannot say that in the case of
martinique uh decisions by
political leaders decisions by the
french state
is just going to be imposing upon the
population and that's it
a public policy i mean memory works and
public commemorations work
if they are appropriated by people
otherwise you can say puja missouri you
can say all kind of things
and it's gonna come back um and
what's interesting is that this the
example that was given by
zaka about the tri-centennial it's
difficult tri-centennial gate
is basically uh it's interesting because
it's
on two levels it's a
the signs of kind of failed memory or
commemorations policies
first nobody knew that this place was
called the tri-centennial gate
apart from dhaka valerian a few
historians from martinique
and um some some historians said that
that
actually walked around the city to find
it there was no i mean it was it's not
it has not been remembered as a colonial
gate it is the entrance of the ceramic
so to that extent it's
a success on part of caesar it's
a place where the carnival stops every
year
some groups stop there and you have like
the final rounds of drums before it's
time to
go to a party for others it's a place
where people just pee you know in public
and it's
it smells really bad i mean it's all
kind it's it's
all kind of it's a place that has all
kind of functions nobody remembers
remember that it was erected for the
tri-centennial of the colonization of
martinique
then the work of reappropriation is
known by a little more people
because people are more with the
contemporary of their reappropriation by
um by koko nekorai that was mentioned by
by dhaka more people were there more
people witnessed it so but
clearly there's something that is
lacking the people
who wanted to destroy the gate or
were contesting this colonial symbol had
no
idea of this work of reappropriation and
if this work of reappropriation was
not fully understood it means that in
terms of transmission
the transmission of our own past there
is something that is missing
and finally during the commission that
we attended and it's
something that we both noticed some
social workers who attend
the you know the commission on memory
and transmission said
this is a place for people who are
homeless
a lot of them are crack addict in fort
de france
so and that is another of our collective
failures and
another of the structural problem that
exists in martinique
uh the fact that the the economy from
the fact that we
we do have a number of social and
economic problems that
are seen are visible in the city
are part of it but i i really think that
all of these
layers need to be addressed and as i
agree 100
with dhaka when it says the work has
been done
the work has been done on you know
memory
symbols and we can do more
that's true but the core of the action
today
might not be exactly there that sparks
more discussions on okay but what to do
exactly but i
let that guy respond
here's a baby
no you you you're absolutely right um
i this this this weird paradox
there's so many examples you know there
was
two statues of cheshire that were
destroyed uh
martin the one in florida france was
absolutely
uh paternalistic and and
you know once you realize what it means
uh it's basically a statue of shall
chair
um leading a a young
a young kid i think it's uh it's it's a
young uh
yeah it's a young kid and breaking with
his with his feet
the shackles of slavery um
and and obviously in terms of of
the the history of it in terms of
what uh what it wanted to transmit
about who did what for the abolition
um the statue in itself um was an insult
and and could be destroyed and or taken
care of or put somewhere else but
not you know in in the center of all the
france
or you know unexplained uh but there was
another one uh in american city which
actually is named after shenzhen
and there's just a plain statue of
shenzhen um
who can be criticized for many things um
but but
um uh mostly was a man ahead of his time
at the moment as a white guy who never
laid foot once in martinique
i i mean yeah
and so in terms of those politics of
memory just behind the statue in the
city of chelsea there was a statue of
cheshire was just him
so nothing paternalistic just you know
honoring the guy and
behind it there's also a huge fresco
made also by another very famous artist
also very engaged artist
who's a friend of coco also as well same
movement
same generation of of local artists
and and was also i think this one is
celebrating a slave insurrection
and it's the frisco is much bigger and
larger
and has more colors than the statue you
should share
i doubt that
some of the people some of the militants
uh who destroyed the statue of chasha
actually paid attention
to this fresco that was behind this the
small statue
i don't think they paid attention to it
but somehow at the same time
maybe they revealed it um so those are
those are
very much paradox and those things were
done 20 years ago 30 years ago 40 years
ago
50 years ago so like once this
conversation started this year
you're like this is this course that
nothing has been done we're the first to
notice the problem
um there's this talk about there is no
memorial for um you know maroons and
and and resistance coming from the
enslaved there's actually i think 22
monuments in martinique
um almost in every city uh celebrating
uh uh maroons and and and freedom
fighters basically uh
you have them you know in roundabouts
you have
them there's some huge uh monuments
um uh in in gemma with with
like stone statues that remembers a
little bit uh what was in on the eastern
island uh you know facing the ocean
to celebrate all the people who died you
know in the middle passage
uh there's there's so many strong
and powerful celebrations of this
industry
uh and somehow because there is this
political void
uh we want to fill it uh with uh
politics of memory
as if more and more and more memory will
somehow solve
all the political problems happening in
the islands and
and i think that's where there is a
disconnect
to me yes thank you i mean it really
strikes me that
um the issue of uh transmission is
really
at the core of um of what is uh
happening that there has been movements
there has been
uh um initiatives
of you know memorialization and
monuments
that have been built and political
activism that has happened in the
relatively recent
past that is either
that are either not remembered
or um have are
disavowed perhaps uh um uh
by a new generation of activists
uh whose uh claims um
seem to be to some extent similar um but
whose uh
means and modes of action um uh
uh are quite different from older
generations
what what is your uh thoughts on on that
is that
um part of the issue part of what's
happening
no it's it's um it's funny because
about two weeks after the you know
coupling of the
statues of shenzhen i was turning 40 so
i i was like okay maybe it's just i'm
getting old and i'm just like becoming
like super reactionary i'm like oh what
are these young people doing
that was really i was like okay this is
that's what's happening
now and then i talk to younger people
who are like we don't really
get it totally so i was like okay maybe
i'm not that old or maybe it's not just
a generational
thing but more seriously um
i think that there's i think it's it's
it it's it
may it puts us in a very difficult
position
first because i'm again i live eight
thousand kilometers from martinique
so it's actually not easy for me to um
even if i'm a scholars or more technical
and i i felt lots of passion
about what was going on in martinique
but still i'm not living there anymore
and that's
in that that's part of the equation and
that's important
but i work on the migration and on the
fact that a lot of people
have had to go away and not come back
it's not just
a matter of my will to be exploring the
world
it's also the fact that it would have
been difficult for me
to have my career if i was to
go back and so my individual history is
part of a more structural history that
is totally key
to understand what's going on today in
martinique that is that we have a very
big demographic problem that is that we
experienced several decades of organized
migration
with a construction of a problem of
other population on the island that was
also a way
to counter the insurrection i mean i'm
going through 30 years of history very
rapidly but that's all part of it
and so i consider that well i have a say
on what's going on there
because i'm also the result of that
history and
the thing is it is very difficult to be
addressing
um the actions of
young people who mobilize
on in a country what it's actually hard
to be a young person
in a country where the unemployment
levels for
the youth is very high
where there's an almost certainty that
for
all of the people involved and probably
you guys and me who grew up in
martinique that we have chronicled in
our systems
that we all know people women with
endometriosis in martinique
that we all know men with uh who died of
prosthetic cancers
and that we are all in a way i mean we
we have that in all of our families
so that's a very important issue and
that to have
young people who just like break stuff
because it's an unbearable situation is
of course something
that is understandable but
the fact i think it's also important to
relate first
our history is largely conditioned by
slavery but it's also 107 years of
stuff that we've been doing since then
all of this stuff conditioned by slavery
but 107 years of
struggles of victories of failures
and i think that it's important i work
on the be medium right now you have lots
of master tcs articles
people who did stuff from the bimidom
there is not one monography academic
monography in the
middle right now lots of archives have
haven't been open
you have like lots of gaps in how
in our history despite these strong
efforts
of local historians who are the really
like the driving force behind
and sometimes in independent scholars
the driving force behind
you know unveiling very important and
key aspects of our history
and there's the political class that at
the same time is pretty competent on a
lot of very technical issues
but it's kind of uh unable to just
propose that has been kind of tucked in
like this sort of like highly
technical discussion about
decentralization without
really being able to think about
a plan for martinique in 2013 2014 2050
considering the challenges that we have
and
at the same time we've you know a very
weird and complex
political party structure in our country
with the failure
and the collapse of the nationalist
movement that were also sites of train
of
political training places where you
learn stuff when you were in a political
movement and a national and this
movement and you were
driving for independence you had to read
stuff you had to be trained to do stuff
and these places where sites of
transmission as well just like the
cermak that was mentioned
the end i mean the place that is
supposed to be the entrance of the
summer it's not just the entrance of the
ceramic anymore but it's cultural
services
of the city of paris during years that
was a place where people would learn
stuff
and get politicized and we realized that
these places in our societies have
collapsed have disappeared um
zakat who is like obsessed with urban
stuff and urban settings can talk about
that but
where are those places and probably
there is a
general generational thing either you
are born in a very militant family and
you know stuff
or you are from my generation and you
went to cermak and you know stuff
um and but for a number of people
they're just like okay i want to know
stuff so
they just follow weird youtube channels
that say you know total nonsense
but have 90 000 followers because people
need
to know more about their history and
it's these gaps that we
are trying willing to to to feel and i
think it's it's key it's actually
important
i've been going all over the place sorry
no just just to further your point um
there is a there's something really
strange that happened
um so recently i was thinking about uh
growing pains you know when you when you
grow up and then
suddenly you know you lose some eyesight
or growing pains
and and and the in the sense of
must fall i i think it might think we
are after ms4
for like like decades now
and and it's almost like an
uh a future of of what happened when
you are not independent you know
formally
but you do have some political autonomy
you do
have some control of your destiny or you
and you have achieved some
uh progress and emancipation some
um but
this there's nothing you don't know how
to formulate
the next step because there's
maybe no discourse there is no
treaties about it you're just making
stuff up as you go
and this idea of having both
you know the political action or
or what we see is
the progress work that we want or that
we can't achieve at a specific time
and the ability to produce
um the the ideas
and the ambitions and the visions that
can help you
uh maybe imagine this next step
in the last two years there was and i
think we were very good at it
and and i think that's one of the
reasons why matt nick is a very specific
place i'm sorry i'm a homer
uh but we were very good at it we have
been very good at it
at having both this action this
political action
that happened after the evolution of
slavery and and like how do you encroach
on political power step by step
sometimes you know by fight sometimes by
political action sometimes by
by you know militancy sometimes by but
there was always a discourse with it
that was going along with it there was
always ideas that were produced that
were going along with it that was that
was basically stating
okay we done this we need to do this
next
and somehow maybe because a generation
disappeared maybe
because the fabric of society itself has
changed
even though you know in the last 50
years or so
there was you know this bimido migration
things have accelerated in the last 20
years
and the way society was shaped at that
time you know i talked about how
all those people coming from the
countryside came to the city
happened what happened at that time was
what happens oftentimes when you have
very different people
all those energies gathering in a city
it's it's paradoxical but
it's almost as if this concentration of
all the different
parts of martinique in cities that
happen
uh you know after maybe after the
eruption of the monopoly and then after
world war ii
were also kind of the source of all
those ideas and
all those and and because people were
living together and they were arguing
with each other they were agreeing next
to each other
and by this this development that we
have known you know all those
those like social economics some of the
socioeconomic progress that have been
made
maybe the ability to travel more maybe
you know
and the fact that people are not people
are living further away from each other
so this fabric of society has changed
and at the same time all the tools that
were created to
foster you know this this living
together
um have have collapsed and there's
nothing to replace them
you know there's there's there's there's
uh so
when i when i came back so i i've been
i've been reading a lot because you know
i come
from from from from people with the
fight so you have to read
very early on you have to be sensitive
to some of the issues you have to be
knowledgeable about them
you need to read more more more that's
almost like you're trained
and but i realized when i was like 18
years old that
most of the knowledge that i was reading
where libraries were
you know so you have to go to this place
or this place but they were not
readily available there was nothing
wikipedia for example to put it simply
there was no program that was made to
make all those things that were
that was knowledge that was already
constituted by previous generation
there was no effort at a time to make it
accessible
and and this problem stayed with us uh
in the last 20 years or so
and maybe it was maybe an occasion
because you know you don't have maybe to
have a
a cultural center because you know times
change um but maybe you could have
thought about something that could be
done
on the internet and everything and what
happened the last few years is just
um um you know people
trying to invest this space and trying
to
and they just grapple our ideas has they
come and
and this produce may be something that
we we do not understand
or or finally be illegitimate
thank you zaka um i want to bring in
into the conversation a question um that
we got through the q and a
function that is coming from elodie
eugenie
and she says thank you for this rich
discussion
you showed that this is a complex
situation
and that we lack uh an overall point of
view uh perspective
and sometimes knowledge of one battles
um with the ideas that
i think she's referring back to some of
the discourse of the
uh noise movement so the question she
asked is
how could you people deal with some ego
maybe
but moreover the fact that bringing
context and nuances
comes with the label of truck
by stockholm syndrome and
i think what she is referring to is
the tensions that exist at the level of
discourse and dialogue in terms of
um you know having a productive
conversation
within that context of the post
summer of 2020.
i think it's actually it's it's it's a
key
question it's a key issue one that we've
tried to address and that will continue
in the coming years
first i i want to specify something
actually
a significant portion of the martening
population was actually in
really upset really upset in the sense
that
oh this was disorder some people like
order also
i mean the the non-cool reactions to
to the event and the fact that some
people were just like um
including people who are like strong
supporters of the mayor of fort de
france who had the impression that the
mayor was just being humiliated etc
was were upset some of them from lower
classes
some of them like from like very working
background and just thinking
what these young people just coming like
insult us in our city
in fort de france and that's part of the
i mean so
actually the the array of reactions to
the issue is actually really wide and
and we
might not be the majority to a certain
extent
the second thing is that it's difficult
it's difficult for a number of reasons
because
your the the way we what we talk about
is
can often be i mean
people can talk about the lack of
legitimacy that we might
have delegitimized are um saying
you're an intellect i mean one that was
coming back often was
oh you intellectuals you now you live
far away from here you're not from here
you don't you you cannot talk but
all you intellectuals as if we had
being a scholar wasn't
was kind of disconnecting you from um
knowing
exactly the society in martinique from
coming from uh very popular and
blue-collar backgrounds in in the case
of martinique so it was not
is it but i think that it's just it's a
very progressive work there is no
there is nothing that we can do to
totally change this and it means kind of
ignoring part of what's going on
on social media kind of ignoring part of
this and just like
do like some deep work just like
advancing and doing stuff
organizing things in the public
organizing
it's been difficult because of the
sanitary contact and we've been on the
lockdown in martinique as well
actually dakan a group of other people
including
myself we created an organization and
that is clearly driving force behind the
whole project
to just like have public arenas of
discussion of all of this stuff like
some very
intellectual stuff like the carnival
claudicon all kind of things and to do
it all over the territory and like
invite people to just
to talk and exchange and do i mean and
we'll do that
we are we have good friend who are
history teachers in high schools and
secondary uh school who launched only
one academe
which is a um an online platform like
doing like small formats video formats
on the local history and i think it's a
multiplication of initiatives
on part of people who have been like
kind of um
apparent by what was going on that is
going to do something and i think that
that
we have to recreate the spaces that have
disappeared we have to recreate them and
that's
actually that's the drive that that we
have right now
to do that kind of things
yeah and i would add to this that um
having a critical
uh outlook on the issues and
uh you know taking an analytical view is
essential to um the movement
uh um actually uh
being understood uh and uh it is not
um uh attempts you know it attempts at
um explicating uh the movement and
explicating
its actions are not attempts at
undermining it
but rather at taking stock of the
significance of those
actions and as scholars whether or not
we agree uh with any particular action
is
really not uh the point necessarily
but it is as scholar and as citizens and
as people from martinique i think it is
essential
that we really think about uh
uh in a in a in a rigorous way uh the
stakes and the issues and the
consequences of those actions
um as a community uh also because it is
shaping us
for the way forward and we want to do it
in a thoughtful way and we want to do it
in a way
that makes us agent of that
uh set of events rather than
just people reacting to outside forces
perhaps
or people reacting to events and
for me it is really what is at the
heart of the intellectual challenge and
you know taking a step back is not
stockholm syndrome it's not
talking the language of some oppressor
is bringing people uh
in front of their responsibilities with
regard to
the political significance of what
they're doing with regard to the
historical significance of their doing
and also appreciate and
underline and shed light on what is
happening also
i i i was raised with a with a very
simple
and i think this is the sentence you
find it in in pretty much all of the
anticipation movements
knowledge is power um
if you want to know uh what you want to
achieve if you want to actually achieve
something you need to know what you want
to achieve
you need to understand how to get there
you need to understand the means to get
there
you need to know what works and what
doesn't and you need to know
what was achieved before you and and
what you need to do
uh after that i mean that's that's very
simple
it's not stockholm syndrome it's just
you know knowing
where you want to go and trying to find
out where you want to go um
and for that you need to build your maps
you need to have your tools
uh and and and those tools are not
always
uh physical tools um that's that's very
simple right side
thank you we have another question
jones um who is also thanking us for
this rich discussion
and asking i wonder if the panelists
could talk about the relationship
of the struggle of a historical memory
and social justice activism
in martinique with similar discourses or
activism
in guadeloupe having visited both places
she says
i was struck by the similarities and
differences
and the role that the new museum of
history and culture
in puente pitch plays in the
conversation
ponta pity is the capital of guadeloupe
maybe just a few words um there's a
very interesting um book on
social movements and the role of trade
union cinematic and guadalupe and
the common point but also the
differences and the level of integration
of trade unions
cultural movements uh in in in uh
in martinique while the work of
representing workers while still
i mean is speaking being taken on by
trade unions in martinique as well but
has been also taken on largely
by political parties and especially the
ppm and in guadalupe you have like this
sort of like
super integrated um
movement that is a movement of defense
of workers but is also a movement
of a cultural movement when they go to
court to defend workers they speak real
because it might make you speak
whether look to speak real um you have
like a whole
very integrated work that's been done
which means that the sites
of social political socialization are
not exactly the same it was not
cultural control or in the open it was
also within
organizations that are still pretty
powerful
uh in in guadalupe that's something that
we saw in
and um the book i'm referring to is a
book by
um uh on the el capi movement
movement o d i n uh
and the k f movement in martinique as
well but you you really see
that the political education of a number
of people in martinique on
memory issues at the same level on
workers rights
is actually within organizations that
are very integrated which is not
exactly the structure that we have in
martial that's part of the answer
because i'm not
uh a specialist of um of uh
of the guadalupe what i so also
but i've been very interested in the
fact i was invited once in a
uh in a festival in guadeloupe for the
commemoration of the
insurrection of slaves in guadalupe and
the aversion of siberian guadalupe
and actually the three or four days of
commemorations
were also the uh occasion to talk about
the lack of hospital in guadeloupe
about workers right about so there was
like this sort of very memory moment
but then there was casey who's a hip-hop
singer of martinique and origin who was
invited to guadalupe to
think she was so it's like come back to
guadalupe and come and
and have this show in front of the audi
that is also your audience
you had workers from the hospital you
had so it was a sort of very integrated
also moment
during which people discussed about
memory and about some
very contemporary and hot topics and i
just feel that this sort of spaces
did not exist at as such
now in martinique but i might be wrong i
don't know what
deck i think about it
no you you're absolutely right
absolutely right well
it's um it's it's very
what's interesting about comparing like
different communities in the diaspora in
general is
is to see how it web heads and flows
you know sometimes you have a community
with who's very much
like avagard in its you know structures
discourses you know how they
localize or how they think about things
and then
it just kind of crumbles and then it
transmits somewhere else and then maybe
sometimes it comes back after
and that's that's very interesting to
you to understand uh
as for the history i think the the
paradox between martinique and guadalupe
is that
uh the the they both have you know this
very strong
uh trade union tradition and i'm gonna
look the emancipation fight
stayed mostly within those trade unions
um and then into you know a more
military or more violent movements that
have
today disappeared mostly that
disappeared actually
while in martinique they transform into
localized political parties
um uh with different you know
visions in terms of policy or or and
goals like you have like those layers
like
ppm for example was kind of independence
but then became an autonomous
party then the generation of the
seventies became
independentist then within the politics
movements there was
there was different schools um you know
the marxist and the trust kissed and
the all at the parties but actually they
were not from the independence
um so you have this very complicated
left then
of course most of those parties that was
kind of for emancipation were coming
from the left wing
um and the scope in martinique is
basically
probably assimilation party uh uh
toward you know total independence
but today in 2020 and that's something
that's very interesting
when we when you think about what
happened this year
for i think since the early 90s
there was two political parties that
have been in power in marching mostly
uh there is almost no pro-assimilation
forces even
right-wing parties in martinique are for
some form of autonomy
or now are even
like saying they are martinican
and and in the last 20 years the two
parties that were in power has been
mostly
uh ppm so the party for me miss isaiah
the progressive party of martinique
which is autonomous but autonomous
towards the end goal of being dependent
in some form
and the independence parties right now
in martinique the head
of the original council of sorry of the
the the economist council of martinique
is one of the founders of the
independence movement of martinique
so you have this paradox right now
the political spectrum its majority is
is
pro towards from autonomy or
independence which means people are
mostly conscious about the current
situation
about you know ideological debates and
about our relationship with france and
our history with friends
you know korea was illegal almost to
talk about talking creole in the 80s now
there's programs and the schools and
there's radio programs and everything
things have changed but at the same time
there is this this this deep feeling of
of something that is not present and
and this is the space that i live in and
that we work in
thank you um we
uh have another uh question from uh
ariela gross
um uh that is uh
she says i'm wondering if you could
speak of to the interplay between the
memory politics happening in martinique
she means by that i think is european
france
um both at the level of the french
government
as well as black lives matter on the
streets in paris
how much interaction is there between
the movements
um well thank you so much ariella for
your uh for your question it's a complex
one actually
but um well what's interesting is that
you clearly have
local dynamics of memory regarding the
memory of slavery in martinique and
the more national dynamics we have you
know if you look at the
uh commemoration of the centennial of
the abolition of slavery you clearly had
uh a strong reluctance on part of france
people pushing including communist
people pushing for the commemoration in
1948
we have local commemorations of um
the and and days that are off during
which i mean people
i don't know how do you say that
holiday it's a 20 or whatever uh but
it's um
you you have those days in in in
in martinique may 22nd in guadalupe may
27th etc so
there are some local dynamics regarding
all of this
uh and you have the national dynamics
that have in
in mainland hexagon or france that have
accelerated
since the end of the um
of the um 1990s
plus the voting of the tobiah law at the
beginning of the years to southern
and uh so you have like this sort of a
catching up on part of the national um
arena public arena you had like the
voting of this law
um in um in 2006 or 2007 i mean the
national day for commemoration that
really people don't care about when
they're in martinique and in guadalupe
maintenance
is a date that is getting more important
in mainland france and that's important
but that is not clearly the focus of
people in in martinique and whether look
they know that it's a little bit that's
not the day that's really acknowledged
the day that's very agnostic that's
important is may 22nd for martinique etc
uh but then there is an articulation on
the number of level
there's an articulation because ever
since they have been
the committee national police clergy now
there's a foundation
people including local historians from
russia have been
um part of the commissions have been
part of the discussion
so there is some maybe not enough but
there's a form of incorporation
of um you know people in uh
the martinique and guadeloupe uh the
reigning island
freshlyanna and on the national level
um now in terms of the um
uh interaction between the black lives
matter i mean the anti-racist movement
in paris and how there was a sort of
like
repeat i mean sort of a black lives
matter uh movement
in in france as well it was actually at
the exact same time then there was all
of this
movements regarding the claudicon and
the toppling of the statues in
martinique so even though people
looked at them and connected them in
terms of the ideas
and there was something and it also
brought legitimacy to what was going on
in martinique it seems to me that there
was a disconnect between the
use including the black hues of um
french caribbean descent that was in the
streets of paris
and what was going on in uh in uh
in in martinique and what loop and in
paris it seems to me that
the connection with the memory of savior
was not direct that was really the thing
of like police violence
and racism addressing racism in a very
straightforward way
and that even though the memory of
slavery is part of the discussion and
the conversation it was not directly
the thing but i think that we would need
to talk about it like very
extensively
thank you i don't know zakah if you have
uh
i i don't i don't really have anything
to add okay okay um
let me turn to another question um uh uh
that i think is uh
uh is an import uh kayama glover
excuse me if i mispronounce the name um
given the remarkable fact that this
conversation is happening
in english at yale among three
francophone thinkers
i guess our accents give us away um
i wonder whether all you all might
reflect
on the intermediary or mediating space
of the united states
when it comes to academic and uh or
activist work in the hexagon and in
martinique
and i can start just with just with the
word as
the person organizing this forum um
indeed in english and indeed atl
and my thinking was that um
the set of events happening in
martinique and
the debate going on around it
that has been quite robust in the last
few months and we've
talked about it a lot we've heard about
it a lot was
of such a relevance way beyond the
confines of martinique that
the broader worlds uh has much to learn
from
the ways in which this particular
section of the diaspora is functioning
right now
within this particular climate
uh that is declining itself globally and
also atmospherically in the americas
um and so i thought it was a very
relevant
and maybe in a bit of uh martinique and
uh hubris that everybody should know
about
what's happening in martinique because
um it's uh it gives much food for fat
um so i don't um
mean by it uh a gesture of uh you know
uh appropriation of the debate for
martinique but uh
on the opposite to shed light to bring a
spotlight on something very interesting
and i think important um going on um
there
there is also the level of um you know
the fact that
i am based uh in in the us and it is
true um that uh the diaspora from the
uh from martinique is extending a way
beyond uh european friends to
many corners of the world and this is a
debate
um that is reaching these corners
because of it
but the fact about displacement is also
part
of the situation that is uh
coming to uh such a boiling point uh
in this moment i mean
the way i i i see uh kayama's
question and and and comments is
actually
we have to go through um
us spaces to actually discuss this is
the very formal and and and
i mean setting it's like it's a cert
talk i'm giving
in uh u.s universities by people who are
interested and sometimes i mean
and in france uh apart from the
foundation foreign
most people accept and that's again
something very interesting in
anglo-american departments and actually
i
my faculty position is in an
anglo-american department
apart from that it's true that the
interest is
people are kind of interested but it's
uh i i
the the fact that we have to i mean in
that case there was clearly this
um everything that you said today is
totally um
true uh and at the same time the lack of
spaces
in the french case to address
this question is just like so
great i don't even know the adjective in
english that i can use to to
to say that um i was
it was really interesting because um
last year i i
attended an event organized by kayama
uh glover at barnard on the digital um
digital caribbean and i was like i
wanted to cry because then you had like
this
room full of caribbean scholars or
scholars of the caribbean
gathering explaining how the digital had
been
important as a space to address a number
of issues that didn't have
enough space in academia and i was like
they don't realize how much space i
have compared to what we have in
mainland france and it was a really
it was a difficult one because even
though i feel really
martinique and i've been here for 22
years you know
and and this kind of space that we're
struggling to create
are sometimes given to us much
in a much easier fashion through us
universities and that's
a reality and it's not going to get
better given the
uh the the the the current context in
in france regarding this kind of studies
that even that have just started to rise
and that already you you already have
like forces that want to correct them
so what thank you so much for the
question and cecile for the space to
actually address all of this
um yeah it's it's it's a it's an
incredible paradox
um and and i know we like very
personally
um it's been so i was living in in
taiwan
for ten years almost and i came back in
much like so of course i left for my
study then i went to work and then
and i went very far away and i came back
four years ago um
and right away my idea uh was
to create a space and bring together
writers and creators and
and you know fiction non-fiction and and
have and so i created a review
and i of course decided to make it
online because it would be easier
to reach out to the diaspora welcome to
the 21st century etc
this was so difficult it was
it's like there was of course there was
people who were willing to give me a
space
and and say hey there's this guy who's
trying to do a cultural and idea review
with martinique
and you know push the envelope with the
only writers and
but there was an overwhelming majority
of people four years ago who explained
to me that it made no sense there was no
need for it
and that was in the local side
uh but i pushed on through and then it
turned out like
some of the things that were coming out
from the review
came even before some of the events that
have been happening like politically
whether with a hero in france actually
sometimes and
and um and for example for example the
analysis
about like the different statues i wrote
it in 2017.
um and um and
and so somehow the the the the review
and the project and the idea that we
need spaces to talk about we need to
produce knowledge we need to produce
fiction
we need to um integrate all those
different narratives and we need to talk
about how we relate to the caribbean how
all of the things are connected to
africa north america france
and we need to produce ourselves these
those spaces
um only make sense kind of now
uh but locally
like it was i received no help no
funding no public funding i went and see
all the institutions
i told them we should do events we
should do this we should do that i
i basically had to fund them myself
myself like i
i couldn't find any help from
local authorities local institutions uh
that have resources that are
uh headed by martin lincoln's and
and they did not see the need for those
spaces of debates
and and it's this year in the last few
months that suddenly
like there's this urgency to realize it
so that begs the question
of once you achieve
some form of emancipation some form of
autonomy
um it doesn't end there and you need to
think about
what is structural what is what is
actually very important
for societies to progress in advance and
keep on pushing and keep on existing
and getting stronger and getting more
vibrant and that
also involves you know having your own
institutions of cultures
and that's what they call soft power
uh it's a very you know real thing in
diplomacy in
political relationships between
countries the united states have
mastered them
and we are sadly smaller players and
maybe one day we will realize
how important it is
well thank you so much um and
incredibly we are out of time
for this webinar i
want to thank our audience for the many
uh excellent foot provoking
and uh courageous questions that came uh
through the question and answers uh
tool we will make sure to send them
to the panelists after the event
and um so that they are made aware of
what
what you guys shared with us um but uh
let me just thank you for coming
and uh listening on thank you to audrey
and zaka
for um uh playing with us uh
at yale and uh rhythm for this
conversation
and thank you to uh matthew taniko
and riddham and professor petey for
um kind of lending us this forum
um i uh
uh i'm uh also happy to say that
the uh session has been recorded and we
hope to be able to share it
uh on the rhythm uh youtube channel uh
soon so we will make sure to uh let
uh you know who has uh registered about
uh where
uh to go and find us to relieve
this uh this moment uh together
uh and share it uh thank you very much
thank you thank you so much
for the questions i i took a quick look
at the various questions it was
created lots of food for so thank you so
much cecil
thank you thank you